bien président vous avez suivi de très
près la colonisation vous ai même fait
un livre dessus ensuite après
l'indépendance de l'algérie vous étiez
alger au service du gouvernement
algérien aujourd'hui j'entends de plus
en plus souvent des gens qui disent
finalement on aurait pu rester là-bas
sur été d'algérie à jane les français
seraient restés comme les blancs sont
restés en afrique du sud
comme cette blouse reste au zimbabwe est
ce que vous croyez pas qu'il quelque
chose d'énorme de rater pendant cette
époque de la colonisation
mais c'est évident c'est cette guerre a
duré beaucoup trop longtemps mais c'est
toujours la même chose on a vu on n'a
pas vu la guerre coloniale
on n'a pas vu la lutte anticolonialiste
d'un pays qui voulait retrouver son
indépendance
on ya vu une révolte de gens qui
habitaient dans trois départements
français puisque l'algérie c'était trois
départements français
et finalement c'est de cette guerre
s'est durci nous nous sommes trouvés
dans une situation invraisemblable qui a
fait que près d'un million de français
léon son parti alors qu'ils auraient pu
rester ainsi on avait compris que
l'algérie pouvait prendre une autre voie
là mais là encore je dirais la
responsabilité des gouvernements
français de l'époque et très grand on
aurait pu reste évidemment l'algérie
aurait été algérienne un état
indépendant c'est normal mais
apparemment il ya des algériens en
france pourquoi pas des français en
algérie abandonné le mythe de l'algérie
française des trois départements et la
chaire algériens qui étaient qui était
grotesque jusqu'au bout c'est ce que
c'est ce qui a été fait et on aurait pu
faire plus à fait autre chose on le voit
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
moi j'étais très ému l'autre jour
j'étais à alger
j'ai rencontré des familles entières de
pieds noirs qui viennent en pèlerinage
retrouver l'inter de leurs parents et et
leurs propres terres sont d'ailleurs
fort bien reçu mon vision quitté
l'algérie mais ils ont toujours
l'algérie aucun a raté un bon truc que
je peux te dire un truc nation
édité chez albin michel
président prenez vous coucher maintenant
oui je vais y aller parce que j'ai l'âge
de faire rentrer pour vous laisser faire
la fête entre jeunes s'y étant ceci
étant vous savez dans le domaine de
l'âge je vous dire deux choses
j'ai connu mois des petits vieux de 20
ans d'épreuves de tran van muylder d'or
qui faisait leur petite carrière vous
savez c'est incroyable moi je n'ai aucun
plan de carrière
et puis je me suis rendu compte qu'on
pouvait être jeune encore très tard et
puis l'autre jour je voyais le président
chirac et je lui disais buzz est en
bonne santé mais depuis ça va mieux vous
avez l'air jeune je dis oui j'ai six
mois de moins que vous et puis françois
mitterrand m'avait enseigné aussi une
chose il m'a dit vous savez la vie
commence à 70 ans aurait encore beaucoup
de temps devant moi
à
et c'est lui
ryan
bon merde t'as raison hervé hervé oui
hervé revenez on veut dire hervé
excusez-moi j'ai oublié de vous demander
un truc
c'est très fort
2e le ch a alors dit moi